Okay, so let's familiarize ourselves with this dataset a little bit
more, and what I really mean here is let's get a little
bit better understanding of the OpenStreetMap project itself and
get started learning what we need to know in order to do
this particular case study. Okay, so I'm actually going to go
ahead and submit a search for Chicago to OpenStreetMap and
you'll see that I get a number of different results here.
The one I'm interested in is this one, the city boundary of
Chicago, Cook County, Illinois, United States of America. Doing this is
essentially going to select from the OpenStreetMap data set,
just that data that has to do with the city of
Chicago. So I'm going to click through to this and you can
see the outline here that identifies the city boundary. And so,
the data that I would be working with is anything that falls
in here. So now if I click export, what's going to happen
is that I'll see the latitude longitude and it's going to tell me,
this is too large to be exported. Okay but
then, if I scroll down, I can see that there
are actually already prepared extracts from this data set. Okay,
so let me make this a little bit bigger. Now
what this is, is pre-prepared extracts from this particular
data set and these are extracts for major metropolitan areas.
So, you can see I've actually clicked on Chicago link
before. I'm going to go ahead and click on that and
then here I have an opportunity to download a zipped up version of this OSM data
as XML. So I click on that and
it begins downloading. And once it's done downloading, then
we can go ahead and take a look at it. Alright, this data is downloaded, I
am going to take a look at it.
It's in my downloads directory. I've already unzipped it,
and here it is. Lots and lots and lots of
XML data. This should look somewhat familiar to you. We've seen
these note tags before and we've actually extracted a little data
from this data set previously. Okay, I'm going to use the
shell command LS, see what the size of this dataset is.
You can see here that it's about 1.8 gigabytes. So, this
is a huge dataset. What this means is that in order
to process this data, we can't really read it into memory.
And so as you'll see a little bit later on, we're going to
use an approach to parsing this that uses a SAX parser, which we did
look at a little bit in a previous lesson. Okay so now, what I
usually do in a situation like this is I explore the data itself a
little bit. I might even write a little code to parse out a
little of what's here just so I can get a feel for it. The
next thing then that we'll want to do is to read enough documentation to
answer any questions that we have or at least enough to get us started.
Okay so what I'm going to do here, then, is simply query for
OpenStreetMap documentation and I can see that there's actually a
Wiki for OpenStreetMap. So if I click through to that,
I land on the Wiki page which gives me quite a bit
of information about OpenStreetMap. Now I'm going to make this ridiculously
big so that you can see it on your screen. And if
we scroll down, you can see there's a lot to read here.
So you can see there's a beginners guide, information for developers, and other
pieces of information - map features, that sort of thing.
I know from having looked at this page before that there's
actually documentation on the XML format which is going to
be useful to us as we move forward. This provides an
example of the different sorts of tags that you're going to
see in this data set and a little bit of an
explanation about it. For example, we can see from this documentation
that this data is essentially instances of 3 different data primitives.
Data primitives being nodes, ways, and relations and
if we click through to any one of
these, we'll get a little bit more information
about them, okay? So I encourage you to take
a look at this documentation for yourself. Make
sure you understand nodes, ways and relations and
you'll be in good shape to more on. Just do a little bit of reading for now.